when you're thinking about trying to
pluck your eyebrows super-thin don't
because like we look gnarly dressed up
hi come on in
how's it going good how are you doing
good awesome get your mark perfectly so
I want you to close your eyes
we're gonna go back in time once you
feel like you're ready I want you to
open your eyes say whatever comes to
your mind first do you want to talk to
yourself should I yeah all right
let's do it how are you brave little I'm
sorry I'm sorry that you feel so alone
and isolated I know you're secured right
now just don't know exactly what's going
on
people around you they just don't
understand right now we want to play
with these toys they want you to play
with the other toys they don't see you
right now the way you see yourself you
didn't have anything to worry about
you're not crazy you are who you say you
are you are one of the boys I remember
every night you would wish that one day
you'd grow up to be this beautiful woman
you really are as beautiful as you
thought that you might be or that some
people told you you are going to be
Wonder Woman when you grow up you're
gonna be okay the future is bumpy and
you think things they're going slow now
the world becomes a much easier place
for people like you there will be
doctors who will help you and understand
you and other people that feel just like
you do and you'll be a part of it
because you're still gonna be here you
will live in a bigger city find other
people that you relate to they're gonna
love you so much they're gonna give you
so much support you have to be patient
because the future is where you can be
free you just got to keep going
you see that first Whoopi Goldberg
special on HBO think to yourself you can
do that you can get paid to make people
laugh your life is no less worthy than
anyone elses because you're trans you
are extra special the world is so big
and there are so many people who are
going through the exact same thing as
you because there's a future that waits
for you that's far less small and scary
than your junior high or your high
school experience I don't want to give
away too much to you you're going to
have an awesome life but always always
try to love your body and always try to
love yourself because that's the most
important thing and I love you
I love you bye cutie going back to the
future I'll see you there bye